[Music]  excellent thank you very much  let's be with me for hard stern  [Music]  [Applause]  green brown orange and gold and a  lipstick cherry cole  man the way she looked that night made  my heart skip a beat i  wish i laid everything on the line i  said baby what's it gonna be how are you  gonna be with me  do you wanna bomb around this town  do you wanna be with me baby  do you wanna bomb around this town drink  it until you're drowned do you wanna be  with me  [Music]  [Music]  cool  [Music]  and the only question to remain here as  far as i can see  do you wanna live with me  do you wanna farm around this town  or do you wanna be with me  drink baby you're drowned do you wanna  be with me  do you wanna fly around this town  do you wanna be with me  [Music]  um  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  be with me baby  [Music]  won't you be with me baby  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you